What’s that in the sky?
Is that a bird?
Superman?
Chemtrails?
Cloud seeding?
What the hell is cloud seeding?
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Humans like to make it rain.
From rain dances to Storm in X-men we’ve
always dreamed of controlling the weather.
Apart from rituals and science fiction, science
might have found a way.
Clouds are made of millions of tiny water
droplets.
But these droplets hang out in the air unless
they stick to tiny particles.
Then they become heavy enough to fall.
Normally these particles are things like dust.
A study published in the journal Geophysical
Research Letters found that pollen might help
form clouds too.
Previously scientists thought that pollen
grains were too large to have any effect on
weather.
Yet this new research suggests that when pollen
gets wet it breaks apart into smaller pieces.
And these smaller pieces could make the building
blocks of clouds.
So it seems like a small leap of logic to
find a way we could help the process along.
Maybe we could make clouds out of thin air.
Sound like science fiction?
Well it’s already a thing.
It’s been a thing in the American west for
decades already.
In California, water agencies and utilities
dish out $3-to-5 million bucks a year on it.
Cloud seeding produces nucleation, when water
particles attach to other small particles
and condenses.
Basically it makes water vapor form clump
into a cloud.
If it gets heavy enough, it falls to the ground
as rain.
One study published in the Journal of Applied
Meteorology and Climatology found that this
process can improve rainfall by up to 15%.
While that doesn’t seem like a lot, this
technique proved effective in a desert in
2010.
An 11 million dollar project produced 52 rain
storms in the Abu Dhabi desert.
In this case, scientists working for the United
Arab government designed ionizers, which produced
charged particles.
As they rose into the atmosphere, these particles
collected dust.
When water particles condensed around the
dust, it formed clouds… which turned into
rain.
Worried your wedding day might be a little
wet?
Well, London based luxury travel company,
Oliver’s Travels can help.
they’ll have a pilot fly near your event
location and sprinkle a few silver iodide
particles into the air a few days before the
shindig.
These particles, look very close to ice on
a molecular level.
So they make water condense and well you get
the idea.
Rain happens.
This clears the air, so clouds won’t build
up on your big day.
Although prepare to cough up a pretty penny.
The service can run $150,000.
I know what you’re thinking - can we just
make a bunch of rainclouds and end the drought?
Well there are some skeptics, one study published
in the journal Atmospheric Research found
some cloud seeding attempts aren’t all that
successful.
Looking over a 50 year period, the researchers
conclude that an increase in rainfall was
the result of chance, not cloud seeding.
But other scientists think it could tame hurricanes.
In a study published in the journal Atmospheric
Science Letters researchers create climate
models to understand how creating clouds could
cool down the oceans.
Hurricanes get whipped by warm waters in the
ocean.
As sea surface temperatures heat up, hurricanes
get more energy.
By creating clouds above ocean hot spots,
the clouds could act like reflectors, bouncing
the sun’s energy back into space.
But on the other hand, such clouds might reduce
rainfall in the Amazon or cause other unintended
consequences.
Which is the main problem with the whole cloud
seeding thing.
You can’t predict the weather, even if you
make it.
So more research is needed.
So it might not save us from a drought, but
could the ocean save us?
Julian finds out in this episode here